good afternoon
today uh
as we watch freedom and liberty under
attack abroad
i'm here to fulfill my responsibilities
under the constitution
to preserve freedom and liberty here in
the united states of america
and it's my honor to introduce to the
country
a daughter of former public school
teachers
a proven consensus builder
an accomplished lawyer
a distinguished jurist
one of the nation's most on one of the
nation's most prestigious courts
my nominee for the united states supreme
court is judge katanji jackson
you know uh four weeks ago when
a member of the court
friend of mine used to work together in
the senate
justice stephen breyer announced his
retirement
i said then choosing someone to serve on
the united states supreme court is one
of the most serious
constitutional responsibility a
president has and i mean it
i promised the process would be rigorous
that i would select a nominee worthy of
justice briar's legacy of excellence and
decency
someone extremely qualified with a
brilliant legal mind with the utmost
character and integrity which equally is
important
and though i would bring
this decision
to this decision my perspective as a
lawyer
former constitutional law professor
chairman of the judiciary committee for
many many years
and i'm almost reluctant to say it
someone has been presided over more
supreme court nominations than almost
anyone
living today which makes me 28 years old
i started doing it when i was 32
and who was devoted much of my career to
thinking about the constitution and the
role of the supreme court
with that perspective
i carefully stuttered to write study the
record of candidates
i've invited senators of both political
parties to offer their ideas and points
of view and i've met with a number of
them
as a result
because i i truly respect not only the
consent i know they give consent but it
said that the constitution says advice
and consent
i sought the advice of democrats and
republicans
i've consulted with leading
legal scholars and lawyers
and i've been fortunate to have the
advice of the vice president harris i
mean this sincerely
an exceptional lawyer a former attorney
general in california and a former
member of the senate judiciary committee
and during this process we look for
someone who like justice breyer has a
pragmatic understanding that the law
must work for the american people
someone who has historical perspective
to understand that the constitution
is a resilient charter of liberty
someone with the wisdom to appreciate
that the constitution protects certain
inalienable rights
rights that fall within the most
fundamental personal freedoms
that our society recognizes
in the end someone with extraordinary
character
will bring to the supreme court an
independent mind
uncompromising integrity and with a
strong moral compass and the courage to
stand up for what she thinks is right
for too long
our government our courts
haven't looked like america
and i believe it's time that we have a
court reflects the full talents and
greatness of our nation with a nominee
of extraordinary qualifications
and that we inspire all young people to
believe that they can one day serve
their country at the highest level
i've admired these traits of pragmatism
historical perspective wisdom character
in the jurors nominated by republican
presidents as well as democratic
presidents
and today
i'm pleased to introduce to the american
people a candidate who continues in this
great tradition
judge jackson grew up in miami florida
and by the way the mayor of miami
republican endorsed you
i thought that was interesting
her parents grew up with segregation but
never gave up hope that their children
would enjoy the true promise of america
her parents graduated from historic
black colleges and became public school
teachers
her mom a principal her dad a teacher
who later went back to school and became
a lawyer representing that very school
district that school board
judge jackson describes finding her love
for the law
from an apartment complex at the
university of miami where her dad was
attending law school
she'd draw in her coloring book at the
dining room table next to her dad's law
books
she grew up to be a star student
elected mayor of her junior high school
and president of her high school class
where she was a standout she was a
standout on the speech and debate team
and it was after a debate tournament
that took place at harvard when she was
in high school
that she believed she could one day be a
student there
there were those who told her she
shouldn't set her sights too high
but she refused to accept limits
others set for her
she had gone to harvard under graduate
school where she graduated magnum [ __ ]
laude
she went into attend harvard law school
where she was a top student and editor
of the prestigious law review
then
she applied for a highly competitive and
coveted clerkship on the united states
supreme court and she was selected
the justice who thought she was worthy
of this high honor was a young lawyer
was none other than justice stephen
breyer
whose seat i'm nominating her to fill
not only did she learn
about being a judge from justice breyer
himself she saw the great rigor through
which justice breyer approached his work
she learned from his willingness to work
with colleagues with different
viewpoints
critical qualities for in my view for
any supreme court justice
now years later
she steps up to fill justice breyer's
place in the court with a uniquely
accomplished and wide-ranging background
she served both in public service
as a federal public defender a federal
public defender
and a private law practice
as an accomplished lawyer
with a prestigious law firm
if confirmed
she will join justice sotomayor
as the only other member of the united
states supreme court who has experience
as a trial court judge
a critical qualification in my view
and once again
following the footsteps of her mentor
justice breyer she'd become the only
member of the court who previously
served as a member of the united states
sentencing commission
and she brings additional perspective to
the court as well
she comes from a family of law
enforcement
with her brother and uncles having
served as police officers
that's one reason i expect by the
fraternal order of police the national
organization today said and i quote
there's little doubt she has the
temperament the intellect and legal
experience and family background have
earned this appointment
and they went on to say
they are confident she will quote
approach her future cases with an open
mind and treat issues related to law
enforcement fairly and justly
incredibly
judge jackson has already been confirmed
by the united states senate three times
first to serve on the u.s sentencing
commission
a bipartisan independent commission i
helped design to reduce the unwarranted
disparities in sentencing
and promote transparency and fairness in
the criminal justice system
on the commission
judge jackson was known for working with
democrats and republicans to find common
ground on critical issues second
she was concerned but confirmed by the
united states senate with bipartisan
support
on the federal district court to
administer justice with the special
rigors and fairness that come presiding
over trials
third
she was confirmed with bipartisan senate
vote to serve on the u.s court of
appeals for the district of columbia
considered the second most powerful
court behind the supreme court itself
in the courts she once argued cases
before as a distinguished advocate
and when judge jackson was nominated to
the circuit court
one of his distinguished retired members
judge thomas griffin
a former general counsel of brigham
young university
and a george bush appointee to the court
said he backed her enthusiastically
hailing her hailing her exemplary legal
career in both public and private
practice
and went on to say
her careful approach as a trial court
judge judge jackson's service on the
district circuit court of the dc circuit
court of appeals is another superb
qualification
for service on the supreme court
three of her of the current supreme
court justices also serve as the tc
circuit judges where john jackson's now
serves
her opinions are always carefully
reasoned
tethered to precedent and demonstrate
reflect respect for how the law impacts
everyday people
it doesn't mean she puts her thumb on
the scale of justice one way or the
other
but she understands the broader impact
of her decisions
whether it's cases addressing the rights
of workers or government service
she cares about making sure that our
democracy works for the american people
she listens
she looks people in the eye lawyers
defendants victims and families
and she strives to ensure that everyone
understands why she made a decision
what the law is and what it means to
them
she strives to be fair
to get it right
to do justice
that's something all of us should
remember
and it's something i've thought about
throughout this process
as a matter of fact i thought about it
walking over here with her
one floor below
we have several displays celebrating
black history month
one of them
includes the judicial oath of office
taken and signed by
justice thurgood marshall himself
an oath
that will be once again administered to
a distinguished american who will help
write the next chapter in the history of
the journey of america
a journey that judge jackson will take
with her family
i hope i don't embarrass him but her
husband patrick i'm a surgeon dr patrick
stand up let him see who you are
there you go
they met when they were undergraduate
students at harvard and he's this
distinguished cancer surgeon at
georgetown
and like so many women in this country
judge jackson is a working mom
she had her eldest child
natalia when she was a private lawyer in
practice she had her second child laila
when she served as uh on the u.s
sentencing commission stand up layla
i asked layla when i showed her through
the office whether she'd like to be
president
there's other things
anyway laila you're welcome to be here
thank you so much
and welcome
your sister who's up in school in rhode
island now
i have children and grandchildren let me
tell you judge
you're always a mom
that's not going to change no matter
what you're doing
you're on whether you're on the supreme
court or not
and i've always had a deep respect for
the supreme court judiciary is a
co-equal branch of the government i mean
it
the court is equally as important as the
presidency or the congress it's co-equal
so today
i'm pleased to nominate judge jackson
will bring extraordinary qualifications
deep experience and intellect and a
rigorous judicial record to the court
judge jackson deserves to be confirmed
as the next justice of the supreme court
i've met with the chairman and ranking
members of the senate judiciary
committee
senator dick durbin
senator chuck grassley and my hope is
that they will move promptly and i know
they'll move fairly
judge jackson congratulations
and the podium is yours let me pull this
out for you
thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much mr president i am
truly humbled by the extraordinary honor
of this nomination
and i am especially grateful for the
care that you have taken in discharging
your constitutional duty in service of
our democracy with all that is going on
in the world today
i also offer my sincerest thanks to you
as well
i'm vice president for your invaluable
role
in this foundation process
i must begin these very brief remarks by
thanking god
for delivering me
to this point in my professional journey
my life has been blessed beyond measure
and i do know
that one can only come this far
by faith
among my many blessings and indeed the
very first is the fact that i was born
in this great country
the united states of america is the
greatest beacon of hope and democracy
the world has ever known
i was also blessed from my early days to
have had a supportive and loving family
my mother and father
who have been married for 54 years
are at their home in florida right now
and i know that they could not be more
proud
it was my father who started me on this
path
when i was a child as
uh the president mentioned
my father made the fateful decision to
trans uh to transition
from his job as a public high school
history teacher and go to law school
some of my earliest memories are of him
sitting at the kitchen table reading his
law books
i watched him study
and he became my first professional role
model
my mother who was also a public high
school teacher provided invaluable
support in those early days working
full-time
to enable my father's career transition
while also guiding and inspiring
four-year-old me
my only sibling my brother kataj
came along half a decade later
and i'm so proud of all that he's
accomplished
after graduating from howard university
he became a police officer and a
detective on some of the toughest
streets in the inner city of baltimore
after that he enlisted
in the army
serving two tours of duty in the middle
east
i believe that he was following the
example set by my uncles who are in law
enforcement
you may have read
that i have one uncle who got caught up
in the drug trade and received a life
sentence that is true
but law enforcement also runs in my
family in addition to my brother i had
two uncles who served decades as police
officers one of whom
became the police chief in my hometown
of miami florida
i am standing here today by the grace of
god as testament to the love and support
that i've received from my family
i have also been blessed with many dear
friends colleagues mentors law clerks
i could not possibly name all of the
people to whom i owe great thanks
but i must mention specifically the
three brilliant jurists
for whom i had the privilege of serving
as a law clerk at the outset of my legal
career
u.s district judge patty sarris in
massachusetts u.s court of appeals bruce
judge bruce celia in rhode island
and last but certainly not least
associate justice stephen breyer of the
supreme court of the united states
justice breyer
in particular
not only gave me the greatest job that
any young lawyer could ever hope to have
but he also exemplified
every day in every way
that a supreme court justice can perform
at the highest level of skill and
integrity while also being guided by
civility
grace
pragmatism
and generosity of spirit
justice breyer the members of the senate
will decide if i fill your seat
but please know
that i could never
fill your shoes
to my dear family
those who are here with me now and those
who are watching from home
i am forever indebted to you for your
love and support
to my beloved husband patrick
thank you for being my rock today and
every day for this these past 26 years i
love you
to my daughters talia and laila you are
the light of my life
please know
that whatever title i may hold or
whatever job i might may have i will
still be your mom
that will never change
there are so many other people i would
love to be able to address and to thank
but
time is short so let me end by sharing
an interesting coincidence that has
actually meant a great deal to me over
the years
as it happens
i share a birthday
with the first black woman ever to be
appointed as a federal judge
the honorable constance baker motley
we were born exactly 49 years to the day
apart
today i proudly stand on judge motley's
shoulders
sharing not only her birthday
but also her steadfast and courageous
commitment to equal justice under law
judge motley's life and career has been
a true inspiration to me
as i have pursued this professional path
and if i am fortunate enough to be
confirmed as the next associates justice
of the supreme court of the united
states
i can only hope that my life and career
my love of this country and the
constitution
and my commitment to upholding the rule
of law and the sacred principles upon
which this great nation was founded
will inspire future generations of
americans
thank you again mr president for this
extraordinary honor
[Applause]
i forgot to introduce the first lady dr
joe biden
and the second gentleman i said seems
strange to say that but the second doug
is imhoff they're both here as well so
thank you thank you all
[Applause]
rock and roll